once i started smoking weed yeah my
whole brain changed
right away i understood how to put
together stand-up comedy i got it the
weed made me understand i go
i it was just a formula you know how to
you know how to set jokes up and
and that's when i started doing a
stand-up because like joe
joe encouraged me to do it and i thought
i could do it now i could
the weed made me understand stand-up for
some reason and it changed my music
i dropped all the heavy [__] right when
i started smoking i dropped all the
heavy [__]
and started playing acoustic and with
with chick singers and started writing
like [__]
like uh mazzy star type stuff and like
sarah mclaughlin
i made a one eight or so i made it 180.
yeah you know
but so so the weed has such an effect
but it sounds like the ability to mask
like i've never dude you just change
that for me like i used to smoke weed
like i'm sober unfortunately right it
[__] sucks but for now it sucks but
um but when i used to smoke weed i
couldn't smoke it after a while because
i got too paranoid yeah because i never
looked at it as
you had too much stress in your life yes
smoke weed when shit's going great
and then it'll go it'll go better but it
weed doesn't make you feel good or bad
it
amplifies whatever you want you can make
it feel whatever you want like some
people
think oh [__] i'm stressed out i better
smoke weed that's be
it works for them because that's what
they believe that right there it's
whatever they wanted to relax
weed makes your brain turn the [__] on
so whatever you want to believe
you want to if you believe weed makes
you paranoid every time you smoke it
you will be paranoid every time you
smoke the first time i smoked weed and
had a positive experience
all other time smoking weed like once a
year would always be a horrible
experience
i'd smoke weed at a party and [__]
freak out and like what happened
hi go sit in the car what um so in 1998
i was i was uh i was in love with the
most beautiful girl
i've ever been with at up at that point
there's a girl from white girl strip
club white girl from kentucky with uh
with a black booty
she played soccer her whole life her
body everyone like
like just fell over with this girl's
body little 23 year old
nice titties from kentucky and
everything almost got a scholarship
playing soccer
those legs were on point yeah everybody
when they when they see her they're like
oh [__] look at that body
so i fell in love with her and uh right
right at the beginning
she came over my house one day and
pulled out a joint so let's smoke a
joint i'm like i'm not gonna smoke weed
i hate wheat
yeah i would i was the anti-weed well
you aren't
you're the opposite of wheat almost as a
humanist yeah i was anti-weed yeah i was
against it so she pulls this with this
he
she pulls out this this spliff and then
what do you do i'm like [__] dad i don't
want to smoke weed but you had to
but she i took a took a [__] rip and
i had the most incredible night
of sex we laughed like mental patience
all night
ordered late night damiano's when it was
around in on fairfax
you could order pizza you had fun three
in the morning we ordered cheesecake
pizza [__] two y'all doing sex or not
yeah yeah but that wasn't really it that
the sex was
great everything was great i'll [__]
anybody on weed yeah
it makes anybody feel like it makes your
wife feel like a different person yeah
yeah
and then the next morning i couldn't i
couldn't believe that had such an
amazing time high
so i didn't get it so the next we tried
it again the next night and the same
thing we had an amazing time then the
next time then i began to realize like
wait a minute weed doesn't make you
paranoid
it makes you whatever you want to make
it so the reason i had a great time
because i fell in love i was in a great
time
because you were already in a great time
yes so i realized really quick
it was an amplifier of your emotions do
you still feel that way about
absolutely wow i've never thought about
it amplifier because physically what it
does is
i don't know how it does it but it makes
blood rush to your
head that's why your eyes get bloodshot
you have all this blood in your head
and blood is good blood is life right so
if blood is
flooding your brain that must mean that
your brain
is flooded with activity and power
you're ready
so either it's gonna [__] make you
paranoid because you can't handle all
that power
or you're gonna learn how to handle all
that power like neo in the matrix at
first he was like what the [__] i can't
he couldn't fight anybody but then by
matrix 3 he's fighting 50 guys in the
sky
because he got it he got all that [__]
down he mastered the power he mastered
the power some people get they get
scared away by the power too much blood
in the brain
they're thinking about two [__] too much
that's what happens to me yeah
and i end up you're gonna often get
scared in my room that's what happens to
me a lot of times yeah yeah that still
happens to me too like if i have
something really stressful
going on in my life like a couple weeks
ago there's a lot of stressful [__]
going on
i wouldn't smoke weed yeah and you know
what it's just going to make me uh
focus on it too much and i want to not
think about it so that was like four or
five days where i wouldn't i wouldn't
you were out i got so high in college
one time um that i called the cops on
myself right and people have done this
right it's pretty normal
um this is popular for i don't know if
it happens to everybody it definitely
happens to white people
where like you get high and call the
cops but there was a party at our place
so everybody's outside [__] partying
so i
the ambulance is coming right so here's
what i did bro
i waited till they were coming in the
front and then i came out the back door
and went and got in the ambulance and
the shotgun right oh my god
and just waited until they came back out
of the party because i don't want to be
embarrassed like
being carried out on a stretch or
anything you know that's crazy i was
still like so self-conscious so i was
just sitting in the ambulance by myself
even though i called it
and they come back and get back in and
they're like uh hello and i was like
yeah i'm the guy that called
let's get the [__] out of here let's go
i've got an iv i'm just sitting on your
front porch wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been